ne mettront pas le chauffage tant que la
température ne sera pas en dessous de 19
degrés la température qui a été retenue
c'est 19°c
donc vous verrez plus avec une cravate
mais avec un col roulé et je pense que
ce sera très bien que ça permettra de
faire des économies d'énergie de faire
preuve de sobriété c'est la manière la
plus efficace de passer l'hiver sans
avoir à couper l'énergie pour qu'il soit
elle le trouvait les gants et beau des
internautes suivent son exemple plus ou
moins ironiquement car cette annonce
suscite beaucoup de moqueries certains
imaginent la création d'un chèque col
roulé de 59 euros quand d'autres se
demandent quel sera la prochaine mesure
du ministre de l'économie porter un
bonnet relancer la cagoule ou pourquoi
pas promouvoir les boudins de porte et
bonjour mon cher Olivier Truchot bonjour
Il est il est parfait ton col roulé
Alain bonjour les grands bonjour à tous
le tien aussi les amis ici dans les
Grandes Gueules nous avons pris monsieur
le ministre de l'économie à la lettre
tout un sac consigne le col roulé cet
hiver pour faire des économies de
chauffage est en col roulé Olivier je
suis en col roulé Monsieur Didier Giroud
agriculteur en Saône-et-Loire est en col
roulé bonjour la France profonde j'ai
qu'une trouille c'est de crever de chaud
quoi
plus belle cravate je dois dire ce matin
et Emmanuel vous vous considérez que la
cravate c'est la réponse justement
je vous imagine assez bien
on pensait avoir les attends les
pâquerettes avec les questions col roulé
dans les matinales on a trouvé mieux la
doudoune de la première ministre qui
fait parler que dis-je qui fait débat
on a vu aussi Isabelle à l'intérieur
avec une doudoune on l'a vu tout à
l'heure mais elle était en déplacement
c'est pas la même doudoune d'ailleurs
qu'elle porte aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il faut expliquer
tu es carrément avec le bonnet la
doudoune l'énorme col roulé écharpe là
c'est au delà de Bruno le merle des
particuliers rémunérés pour utiliser
moins d'électricité les géants de
l'énergie des gaines des primes des
bonus
pour récompenser les bons élèves et
soulager au passage le réseau français
des gens qui ont tellement d'argent ils
peuvent faire des choses vraiment très
intéressantes quoi je trouve quand tu es
à Portofino et que tu décides d'aller
dîner au rides un soir en prenant un
avion privé je trouve c'est la fin du
monde quoi
tu vois ça veut dire tu as rien d'autre
à toute quoi c'est l'ennui absolue
parce que c'est un chauffage au sol il
faudrait tout casser pour le rétablir il
est il est il est en panne donc j'ai pas
de chauffage depuis des années et que
l'hiver vous traversez la absolument
l'hiver vous êtes pas sérieux je vous
assure la machine à café ne pas la
laisser en veille donc débrancher
l'électroménager dont on utilise pas
même chose pour le lave-vaisselle cet
hiver si l'économie 5% d'électricité
totale énergie lui versera 30 euros
printemps 20% de consommation en moins
et c'est 120 euros de récompense seule
condition être abonné depuis un an et
possédez un compteur intelligent Linky
j'attends de savoir quelle couleur le
matin il faut que je mette ma culotte
pour enfin tu vois je bloque le rouge
comme d'habitude non mais j'attends
franchement j'attends pas ça des
politiques quoi enfin moi j'aimerais que
les ministres ils soient au travail pour
régler ses problèmes d'énergie
ah bah là je peux je peux je peux danser
je peux te marquer ah bah ça ça va
plaire à notre fan de danse Aïssatou
vas-y Lucie vas-y Lucie
alors là c'est galbe et cette tenue
franchement mais en valeur ses fesses là
tu as le boule qui se chamboule
direction le mois de décembre 2022
images BFM TV vous voyez ici la sortie
du Conseil des ministres qui vient tout
juste de se terminer conseil dont le
porte-parole Olivier Véran s'apprête à
faire le compte rendu
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs tout d'abord un
petit mot pour vous dire je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver payer les
particuliers pour les inciter à la
sobriété
même principe chez engie pour
l'électricité mais uniquement quelques
jours par mois cet hiver en cas de
tension sur le réseau
là encore à la clé une récompense
financière
des gestes alors que les géants de
l'énergie enregistrent des bénéfices
record au premier semestre plus de 10
milliards d'euros pour total 5 milliards
pour engie il reste une heure pour
l'instant pour l'instant ça va
c'était quoi ça c'est le bol ouais c'est
le bol je veux pas dormir
invitez aussi Francis Huster qui se
réjouissait de la diversité de la foule
en voyant un drapeau algérien à l'image
et c'est beau de voir un drapeau
marocain justement la France c'était une
paire et je crois que maintenant c'est
une terre sportive aussi la fin du monde
c'est pour demain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]